the cost of borrowing is coming down for
the first time since the 2008 financial
crisis the Federal Reserve cut interest
rates the central bank lowered the
benchmark federal funds rate by a
quarter percentage point just yesterday
the decision could make it easier for
consumers to borrow money on everything
from credit cards to car loans CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with a look at the feds decision
and what it means for your wallet I'm a
little confused because the economy is
supposed to be doing well and yet we
have the Federal Reserve cut against
interest rates why well the Fed says
that global growth is starting to impact
us Brooke things are slowing down so
you're right even the central bankers
are saying things are good they're not
great they're concerned about that
deceleration and one of the things they
noted as a rationale for cutting rates
the trade uncertainties which is really
crimping growth I think that's a big
issue and finally they're worried that
prices are not rising fast enough it may
be seen seem a little bit weird to
imagine this the Fed wants a little bit
of inflation but not too much inflation
and the reason is they want people to
get wage increases and to spend more
money in the economy that was their
joint rationale how does this affect
consumers that's the best question
because you know really we only care
about the Federal Reserve as it pertains
to our lives and weirdly don't gloss
over the Fed controls almost everything
we do so let's say you're a saver you
got a bunch of money in the bank you're
not happy Fed cuts rates are gonna earn
a little less interest conversely if you
are a borrower you're starting to dance
a little jig say wait I know my credit
card balance I want to whittle it down
it is expensive to carry credit card
balances it'll get a little less
expensive
what about mortgages student loan debt
Jill so mortgages key off of a different
rate it's a longer term rate but the
good news there is that long term
mortgage rates are at three year lows
and when you think about student loans
probably not a lot of help their student
loan rates for the federal program are
set once a year they were just set early
in July they're down a little bit but
they're not gonna move and so those are
in stone if you have a private student
loan and it's a variable loan you may
see some relief so here's what
everyone's afraid of does this mean that
there are signs a recession is on the
horizon that's not what the Federal
Reserve is saying and I don't speak to
economists who say an
into recession is upon us what they are
saying is this slowdown is happening the
Fed wants to get ahead of it that's the
reason why they're cutting rates today
whether or not we see a recession
anytime soon is anyone's guess
anyone's guess you heard it from Jill
right I'm not going on the record with
that well thank you